all right the universities are an
absolute wreck hey you know right now
there are pygmies I'm telling you they
must pay they are the most they are
passive wormed you as a man you cannot
possibly know what I'm talking about in
a time when more and more students on
college campuses are demanding political
correctness from those around them how
have faculty responded recent TV's
editor-in-chief Nick Gillespie sat down
with college professor author and social
critic Camille Paglia at reason weekend
to talk about that as well as feminism
princess career of Beyonce's lemonade
album and more let's get started here
part of what we're talking about this
weekend reason is kind of the state of
the university and you know what is the
is the university over as a meaningful
place as a site of new cultural
production and knowledge and we're going
to be talking you know about students
and the way students are controlled but
can you talk a little bit how do you
feel about the state of the university
from the professor's point of view our
professors particularly in the arts and
the humanities and the social sciences
are they bringing what they should be
bringing to YouTube research universe
alright the universities aren't
absolutely wrecked you know right now
because it for those four decades I mean
any graduate student in the humanities
who had independent thinking it was
driven out okay there was there's no way
to survive without memorizing all these
stupid bromides with with this
reverential bowing to these overinflated
figures like lack home Jerry da Foucault
and so on and basically it's been a
tyranny in the humanities because the
professors who have now my age who are
they were the baby-boom professors who
made their careers on the back of hukou
and so on I determined that that
survived and so you have a kind of vamp
vampirism going on I've been getting
letters I think any letters for you know
for 25 years since since sexual persona
was released in 1990 from refugees from
the graduate schools ok so there's been
just been it's been a terrible loss one
of my favorite letters was an early on a
woman wrote to me who she was
she was painting houses in st. Louis and
she said that she had wanted a career as
a literature professor and had gone into
the a graduate program in comparative
literature at Berkeley and finally she
was forced to drop out because she said
every time she would express enthusiasm
for a work they were studying in the
seminar there everyone would look at her
as if she had in some way created a
terrible error of taste oh my god okay
that's what's been going on is that a
certain some pretentious style
superiority to the text and every text
of course is supposed to be dissolving
itself and so it's all self reflexive at
the end nothing means anything and in
professors believe that they have
something this is an accomplishment to
reduce great works of art to nothing can
I can I have one thing when done so that
graduate training has been
systematically removing from the grad
students the one thing you need as a
teacher in the undergraduate classroom
enthusiasm passion and diction okay an
independent point of view then so I
don't think she mentioned letters I
highly recommend if you don't read her I
guess it's weekly column at salon where
she's been at a mill has been an advice
columnist for 20 years or so and I
magazine oh okay and along with I think
Andrew W K who is a music and musician
and motivational speaker in the Village
Voice these are the two great advice
columnist like forget Ann Landers forget
Dear Abby and the range of topics that
you cover and it's I mean it's really a
fantastic thing you know the wouldn't
win Spy magazine announced my debut an
agony aunt column asked you know it was
on the same cover that they had the
great Hillary Clinton dominatrix cover
okay so I mean I mean spend fantastic
there's like there's this Hillary
Clinton I went on during the White House
team the Oval Office desk in a
dominatrix outfit and then around
there's a band and communal Polly aw
eken the anchor ask so what needs to
joint it hip or what pen change Mel in
the university to bring that back and
because held in rebellion by the grad
students this is what I'm trying to
foment and we absolutely need someone to
stand up
and start criticizing authority figures
but but no this generation of young
people have been trained throughout
middle school and high school and
college okay to be subservient to
Authority there is no question of
authority whatever they want an
expansion authority everything of my
generation stood against it we drove you
know the administrators out of our
private lives out of the inlet loco
parentis oh and now today's kids been
raised in a helicopter parent you know
fashion they want they feel warm and
cozy okay by additional expansion of you
know thirty of these buttons hey hey you
know what people it's mediocrity so who
like the bureaucrats Oh Oh infest
university the university life has
become increasingly unpalatable because
of this thanks to federal regulations
you know forcing the adding on and
adding on and anything out of more
layers of bureaucracy it's a nightmare
and outrage and none of the faculty have
fought back now they pretend to be
leftist okay not pygmies I'm telling you
they must pay they are the most they are
passive worms okay not to fight back
against the bureaucrats so um Chuck
talked a bit about you know in the in
the 60s I mean there's a great moment in
Berkeley with the Free Speech Movement
which started when students and I guess
it was a grad student stood up and
protested at Berkeley in the 60s unless
you were an official member of the
democratic or republican students groups
you couldn't leaflet and that's what the
Free Speech Movement was actually about
about just handing out all sorts of
literature where do you see I mean is
there going to be like who is going to
be you know the university's tank man
and tmn Square carrying his shopping
bags and Santa got well I mean there has
to be a rollback the faculty has been
absolutely Servian nature to this this
bad overgrowth of authority I mean I
wrote a piece 1992 called the nursery
school campus that was very prophetic it
was in The Times Literary Supplement in
England and they queried me when the
article was impressed and they said what
is this Dean of Students thing that you
refer to I said you don't have a Dean of
Students he said no I said you what do
you have it turns out okay Oxford and
Cambridge okay there was practically no
administrative bureaucracy of any kind
he said oh we do have the man who runs
the cafeteria it's I'm sorry so the
provost and
you know in the heads of everything are
like drawn from the faculty and then
when they're done with that position
they go back to the faculty but what's
happened in which is we're extremely in
a pernicious and toxic in American
universities over the last 35 to 40
years phases growth of a massive
administrator class what hadn't had
never had any teaching experience
whatever in regard themselves as a
master race and I am not kidding okay
and and they forced you into every kind
of all kinds of formulas you have to
follow deal with the students and and
every kind of regulation in law in a
bunch of nervous Nellie's etc okay it's
an outrage and there's no there is no
work but faculty has been has been
reduced okay just slaves stats they're
serfs if I'm from coast to coast here
it's an absolute outrage and and again
here all these people pretend like
Judith Butler these people pretending to
be leftist okay and then in the in being
paid you know half million dollars or
cover the yearly salaries and having a
with it with their you know armies of
editorial assistants and people running
it the corruption has been untouched by
the major media what why because they
because all these graduates of the elite
schools go and get jobs the New York
Times okay that's why I you know so
there's definitely that bureaucratic
encroachment on all sorts of university
life and talk it you know you mentioned
Foucault Derrida Lacan and it's
interesting
Jacques Lacan is a French psychoanalyst
who actually was the hero of a 1978
recent cover story called Frances new
anti status philosophy it was I did not
discover that when I was in grad school
I would have loved it would have made
all the Lacanian zat SUNY Buffalo cry
themselves to sleep to know that reason
had something good about him but what
what is and these are very different
guys with different ideas but what is
the kind of overall messy or idea that
they were giving that has made do you
think that has led to ik forma T of
thought among professor well the number
one error of like on their dad Foucault
and so on okay is that is that language
structures everything there is no
reality there's in knowledge is not
possible okay without language and I'm
anything in these it is in here get all
these decades of crap pouring out of
these elite schools based on the stupid
idea I've been
art schools in my entire career excuse
me my dancers are totally inarticulate
that's not how they how they perceive
the world okay they express it they
process the world through the body maybe
they just didn't have the right English
teacher that is know how my ceramicists
do not process the word this is them
anyone who works with their hands is not
processing reality through language okay
this what this is it all based on an
outmoded linguistics of so sure okay
absolute nonsense I write right from the
start there are different parts of the
brain these people there they're all
scientific illiteracy okay which is why
there's no biology as a required element
in women's studies which wouldn't you
think when you're putting together
Women's Studies program that the first
thing would be that any that any
graduate of that program would need to
have one course maybe in biology to
study endocrinology and hormones oh and
so on right it's all language it's all
language and that's why Jen there is
nothing but language you see okay right
go into this transgender nightmare okay
over here is transgender it's become
because they honestly believe that
gender is not grounded in the body they
have absolutely no scientific knowledge
okay people to humanity um talk the led
leads to my next question this is a
group that leans towards the scientific
I think a lot of the people work here
have an engineering background we heard
last night from a congressman who has a
BA and an MA from MIT we heard earlier
from somebody from Caltech this morning
who put down MIT for not really being a
very good school you just may make the
case to a room of people who are
interested in the humanities but maybe
not grounded in what what is you know
why should we study the humanik what's
the value my views are quite
old-fashioned and which is that right
now that that American universities
colleges are are choked with meaningless
electives which fragment knowledge and
simply allow a professor boondoggle and
to be in to be using a class in to
generate ideas for his or her own
research ok now I believe in the great
survey courses I believe in history and
structure I want I would like to cut and
sweep out 60% of the electives the
cafeteria menu which is I think a plague
and which has produced these graduates
know absolutely nothing and I'm really
not kidding they know I
I encounter these graduates of the elite
schools on in the media and if their
minds are utterly unformed in one grand
thing they know nothing they know all
the current indi ology that's it what
I'm saying is that again I said before
there are different parts of the brain
and there's one part of the brain that's
a dreaming part that is the imaginative
part that projects meaning into human
existence
I believe in meaning I don't believe in
dickensian deconstructing or destroying
meaning in my in my undergraduates okay
so that's actually even these people
people like you but you do wait I'm
still I'm still on the roll but I wanted
to go back I wanted to go back hormones
what I'm saying if the in terms of the
value okay the art it is to me one of
the ultimate in creation of the human
spirit and I also I might intervene on
an atheist i ground or in religion art
began as religion that is the theme
actually of sexual persona it begins by
showing the worldview of the Stone Age
me I believe that art has the ability to
condense okay the whole the whole of
human life into you to unite all all the
races all the cultures all the societies
at these moments moments of the flash of
insight of a they give you the meaning
of human life
that's what humanities teaching should
be about but has ceased to be a as the
professor thinks that it is his or her
obligation to transport an external
ideology okay into the classroom and I'm
completely boast of this this use of the
classroom for advocacy there are many
many scandals going on in American
academia there are completely
unaddressed dependent by the major media
what are the in what what is the course
that every every science major every
economics major every Women's Studies
major every English majors hey is there
what well course I would have want it is
now being destroyed everywhere okay
except where there is on a rebellion you
know by graduates you know by alumni and
that is the grade art history survey
course they which it which I these
registers are capable of teaching
because they believe it's all about a
false narrative of straight okay those
courses that began a two semester course
it began in still in age
in art and goes all the way down to
modernism and Jackson Pollock and so on
it gives you the sweep and the varieties
is exactly for the non nature and those
in those courses you know are
disappearing and they are and it's
almost impossible to imagine bringing
them back because because the graduate
students have such small minds now and
then have been trained in terms of the
big idea I believe in big ideas what is
the who are what is the art form of
contemporary contemporary art from that
that excite well of music I mean I can
try an art of song lyric course and and
you know and what I do in that course is
to is to present history and chronology
and tradition major to the students and
to in to create order out of this
tremendous like swirl of music that
they're inundated what they have met
everything is available to them okay but
they have no sense whatever of history
none and in any field I'm saying hey
they're educated public public school
education completely atrocious and it's
a failure to present a history as like a
huge thing they weren't released to us
now and and to be clear I mean you want
to argue about that history right you're
not you're not preaching that the you
know or that there is some kind of
received history that we should be
following as much as there's a timeline
and then let well I don't know no no not
at all no I believe in the arts or in I
believe that you can you can detect
influence and through the generation and
so you know like just my last class
yesterday in the art of song we're okay
I'm getting demonstrating how James
Brown they birthed the fall a which gave
birth this in here is that you can see
we see this you know this cascading of
influence that is a great obsession of
mine to demonstrate the cohesiveness of
art history and all his genre
talk about you know you mentioned James
Brown you mentioned funk Prince just
died Prince is a fascinating character
because he's an androgyne he was
unbelievably sexual he made gestures
constantly to the heavens and his lyrics
and in his playing and yet he was also
in unbelievably filthy as as a performer
and as a lyricist
you know what are your thoughts on
Prince now that
well rinsed was the next step from her
games and huh okay and but in whipped um
what Prince added you funk funk funk was
all about pure sex you know pelvic
thrusts and giant boards come
overwhelming almost fascist style and
what Prince did do it was it was make it
a very intimate and actually restore
tenderness and love okay do it hey so
you're sexy but I love fat on alright um
and the point what you mentioned okay
that conflation of sexuality and
spirituality is not it's not that unique
difference it is one of the outstanding
elements of African American culture
which I demonstrate in my art of song
lyrics course because all the way back
to West Africa okay and it so there's
like the enormity in the power of the
gospel tradition in african-american
life I and the passion in design and in
the soul movement of soul music in the
1960s where there's a direct transfer of
gospel style singing and themes okay
into a romantic context you can see in
Marvin Gaye and then the masterpiece
what's going on I can send anyone so on
right so there's a fusion game that I
think is ultimately what Stefan um you
know how do your students take this and
and the reason I bring this up is when
Prince died my first thoughts almost
went to the way that chipper bore who in
the in the mid 80 started a group called
the parents music Resource Center which
tried first to block certain types of
songs from being released or then then
putting stickers on them and she and Al
Gore Al Gore engineered a Senate hearing
where they kept talking about how the
government had no role in this but you
know we should be putting stickers on
things and we're in the Senate but we
really want to assure you that there's
no government involvement etc but tipper
gore actually mentions a prince song
darling Nikki which is an absolutely
filthy song that she had bought an album
for her daughter who was then 12 or 13
the Purple Rain soundtrack album which
had been at the top of the charts for
like a year almost by the time but they
listened together and they were
embarrassed by the you know just the
sensuality and the the sexualization of
the song are you and that's that led her
to start the PMRC and get this whole
kind of thing going are your students
like
or like it especially because you're
saying they're helicoptered they're you
know kind of slammed up they mean our
kids grow up in institutional settings
do they respond to this are they like
come on mom well no it's interesting
because this generation has grown up
with a this amount of arid flesh
clothing and sex everywhere and video
games and so forth but it's not that
they're prudish but I have careful okay
I feel like it's not that I have I do
trigger warnings very worried about
micro aggression like that I would
attempt to think you are your own
trigger warning so I think it's
appropriate I think I think there's a
question of appropriateness and I just
been very aware okay that oh that it may
be over the last 10 50 here that you
cannot even they don't find anything
about sex funny okay there's not there's
no way to jump to make a joke I hate in
fact in fact I think sense of humor in
general is waning and they don't have
the kind of raqqa sense of humor of
these let's say the ethnic generations
and Jews and Italians emerge you know
from the kind of working-class past so
um I mean that's why I don't if you add
a sex everywhere and yet they seemed
embarrassed by that's and talking about
um you know one of the things that you
started out early on saying that you're
a libertarian or that you consider
yourself libertarian and I think you and
I share an interest in using it as an
adjective rather than as a noun that we
you know we have libertarian impulses
libertarian interests you recently had a
very good conversation with Tyler Cowen
at George Mason that's up online that
you can find you said I'm not saying we
need to return to anything I'm a
libertarian that's why I'm always freely
offending both sides and to give you the
chance to offend some people here
perhaps in a way that they haven't been
yet it you know it talked a little bit
about you are a Democrat libertarians to
the extent you know and we're all
smaller libertarians here to the extent
that they tend to identify with either
Republican or democratic party tends to
be Republican you made a good pace for
the Humanities make a good pace for wide
liberty small-l libertarians should be
flooding with them
well I mean I'm a lien ated from the
current party structure I'd like is
gonna smash the DNC and I've been
supporting Bernie Sanders the insurgent
movement but I love the kind of Hubert
Humphrey hero a hapless Democrat and I'm
in and um you know I but I believe there
is a role okay for her government terms
of public welfare and care for the needy
in the week and come on but I oppose a
load of government and intrusion of
regulation oh and I believe that
something should be built into
governmental structure and including
even at the diversity level okay to
constantly be critiquing bureaucracy as
it inevitably swells and reducing it and
bureaucracy in it you can see it
everywhere in human history bureaucracy
is is the result of a civilization that
devised rigidly a very very cohesive and
positive sense of order and hierarchy
and that is how irrigation has brought a
to the desert you know in ancient
Babylon ancient Assyria and so on
through this hierarchical organization
and planning but in every culture over
time its I read essentially the
bureaucracy swells as puzzles
parasitically and the whole structure
eventually collapses from it is a
bureaucrat by definition is not an
original and find your the original
entity bureaucrat a is is it is a
parasite okay so you see the Rome fell
in this way Rome got too big you know
because of it you can see it seems
happen pressure it everywhere do you
want to be there when it happens in the
US or has it already happen or do you
want to be a collapse either when it
collapses or the civilization well I
mean I I have been warning I've been
warning in the morning I'll pay for for
20 years now that a Western civilization
is obviously in its decline it's so
obvious because as I analyze history in
did in sexual persona when you get when
you start to get transgender phenomenon
when you start to get at a sophisticated
toleration of homosexuality
okay by the urbane you know the
metropolitan elite okay that's a sign
that the kinetic cultures start to say
so what is the better to call myself a
deckhand I love that
I love the trend a transgender period
okay but but there's absolutely no way
you can see in fact uh which book at
what was it my publisher asked ash asked
to lighten up okay they never asked me
to do anything except they asked me to
lighten up at the end of one of my
purposes cover in Ville s and here's
whatever brought where I was actually
saying I said Western they said they
found it too depressing the idea that
the cost was on the window let's for a
last comment here and then we'll open it
up questions
you mentioned sexual persona at which
showed up in 2013 the LA Times s David
Bowie to list his hundred paper books or
most influential books and it's a
phenomenal list I mean it's really you
could spend the rest of your life
becoming very smart reading what he
thought were important books including
yours yes David Bowie also you know
possibly the greatest instantiation of
androgyny and of sexual all sorts of
things Tucket he died this year along
with you know I don't know who's next in
the great pantheon of kind of
transsexual figures but what are your
thoughts on David Bowie's passing and
his influence well yeah I wrote it this
peaceful in the Victorian Albert him did
the giant costume show David Bowie's
government from his warehouses and it's
like been a blockbuster was like the
biggest biggest ticket sales in history
of the DNA and it's been is still
touring the world and so they they
apparently Bowie tell them that a speech
could be with the essay on gender in
Bowie to the catalog I think is one of
my most important pieces is called a
theater of gender David Bowie at the
climax of the sexual revolution I'm
demonstrating which is now completely
forgotten okay they actually what he was
doing by going in the drag direction was
contrary and to where we're a gay we're
home the game movement was going the
1970s a gay man moved into the clone war
very macho hey I think and they rejected
feminist a in the in the ask a while and
a kind of heritage of the camp penis
elegance everything had to do with art
aids or when I went off the conduct but
boys to me like one of the absolute
major artistic big of our time and doing
this research budget of course be a year
it really demonstrates me how are you
that he was how sophisticated how much
he knew about the
about B parts and once actually in the
early 90s he fight dating I mean it was
a fiasco he tried to repeat he tried to
reach me I got a message to my publisher
David Bowie wants your phone number
and I burst out laughing I said oh
that's that is like I said takes the
cake all right David Bowie wants my
phone number and obviously some crazy
man and so I completely dismissed it
well David Bowie didn't want my phone
number anyway he wanted he wanted to
quote from sexual persona in an album
that he was doing right and so I've
missed that so I feel very embarrassed
and still about that is this the best
time to be a woman and to be an
individual we may be in a decline from I
don't know whenever but you know is
there equity not in terms of gender
equity and not in terms of some kind of
bureaucrat bureaucratized
standard but is do women have more
opportunities to shape their own lives
now than at any point in question
absolutely they have their and where
does I come from you have the
opportunity from capitalism hello
okay capitalism came along okay suddenly
hey women were emancipated and we're
finally had the ability to work outside
the home and not to be dependent any
longer on father or husband brother okay
so hang so via feminism OS capitalism
and an enormous debt and but refuses to
acknowledge it however okay yes women
have tremendous opportunities now to
shape their own lives and to into into
in to support themselves and in a huge
array of you know professional careers
to move into but there's tremendous
unhappiness tremendous unhappiness and I
think the discussion is almost
impossible to carry forward because
every time you try to raise biology
biological issues okay so regard people
start screaming at you and saying you're
trying to push women back and just to be
like you know baby baby machines etc etc
anyway what my analysis is someone who's
like studies the whole history of man
and kind that you know that the human
species has four or a million year they
have got gone into making in what today
would be teenage gear the girls were
getting married and having children in
their late teens that's even a little
bit late all of a sudden we have the
this technocratic system that's offered
tremendous freedom and autonomy women to
live like men okay but the idea that our
hormone are somehow able to suddenly
adjust into this radical shift it's like
in like stupid there's like absolutely
no study of it and that's the no
discussion of it I see on women very
unhappy I see you know I see in
professional women extremely unhappy I
feel that that now there is this forced
feeder going on a young girl is talented
and she's intelligent they'd never done
her parents want the best for her but
she just she just felt she's told here's
the track and you're going to leave high
school and you're going to go to college
and then if you go to going to a
professional school you'll go to
professional school and so on this
infinite postponement okay amazing
enough settling down it's a if a young
girl says you know I don't feel like
going to college into an upper middle
class family in Westchester New York I
don't feel like going to college I feel
like any marriage oh you're wasting your
talents okay yeah you're wasting your
talent you're wasting your life a to
follow the promptings of you know your
biology and to make in to marry and to
mate and to have children at an early
Italy period now I personally believe
that it's healthier for women to have
children early and it's a terrible
choice because then oh then I'll be on
the mountain and you'll be on the mommy
track you'll lose power you lose you'll
lose material advantages in the world
okay we have we have this thing where I
see misery everywhere I see bitching by
women at every level okay of the middle
class the middle middle middle class in
the upper middle class okay
they are extremely unhappy in what I see
is working-class pulling with young
women okay barring early having children
early being grandmothers by that time
they're in their thirties and forties
and I witnesses it's like on the Jersey
Shore
I got he'll walk along the shore and I
see all these families working-class
families well who like alright the
motels and they have like a huge multi
generations are on I'm going look at all
this look at the obvious happiness with
them with their children all their
children I tell you said now you're
sounding like a nostalgic this is like
watch out this is like watch what I mean
okay immediately the value job that
mediate the value of the Irish
immediately okay all right not listening
I'm one of the great observers of the
screw up on the Jersey Shore trust a
lower middle class family we hated sorry
I'm sorry
what just were just like the world I'm
sorry I don't know what I am talking
about is absolutely major okay
the misery and unhappiness okay over the
professional class I see it everywhere I
go to Brazil I go to Norway you know I
go to England okay and so on and I hear
the same complaints I see the same
unhappiness the same disjunction
okay there's tremendous unhappiness in
the heterosexual world all right we are
we have not adjusted yet okay check two
women moving into this cold mechanism
okay
is this fabulous and productive
mechanism that has allowed women to be
you know to have autonomy and to in to
lead their own lives without dependency
okay but there are all kinds of
biological things that we have no
language for we have no way to measure
okay and and there's a kind of just a
disrespect for you see immediately okay
you want to squelch it let me go
squelching I got a disagreement that's
not as a man you cannot possibly know
what I'm talking about because you can
tell you are the man that brought y'all
grass man okay a star somewhere star man
okay amen
what is your take on Beyonce and lemony
her visual album I haven't seen it okay
yet but you know all I've seen is the
publicity about it but to me it looks
currently overblown I find it very
vulgar okay to be when you have a child
to be advertising your that child's
father's infidelities I think that it's
gross
Angra test in fact I think she's
extremely talented but I but I regard to
her as um no as some over-the-top ain't
what I mean yeah she's she's incredibly
talented but her singing style is gotten
a megalomaniacal okay all right which
superstars do you know they get into
that mode Barbra Streisand got into it
you know it's going point and I quote it
off the emperor Ian you know compared to
her the wonderful skill you know and
subtlety of Bryson's early phrasing so
on I just think that you know Beyonce is
I'm a feminist but I'm also going to
carp about my you know my you know my my
husband's lovers and Gaza for hi thank
you I don't why the height so you know
it's funny because you're you know a lot
of people reading your work or like oh
you know you're talking you see
pornography everywhere you see sex and
eroticism and yet you're also extremely
moralistic don't you think and I don't
say that no bad way I'm just as a
description well the point is I you know
I'm great fan of the early Madonna okay
with where they were where her
exhibition of the body her her use of
pornographic tropes was very disciplined
and really and I think as she was
working with European directors and her
in her videos and so on and I think
we're into a period now where people
have because we've lost any sense of
limits there's nothing erotic now it's
not if not not least that I moralist
it's at you know I adore are truly um
erotic pornography but it's not being
made now okay it the bet that you really
the most erotic period was that moment
when this Hollywood studio system was
breaking down and you had Marilyn Monroe
okay you know it was like was straining
at the limits of it and funny you have
Elizabeth Taylor and Butterfield 8 which
is practically my canonical work okay as
a high is a high-class call-girl she
wouldn't die quick enough so spoiler
alert she couldn't die quick enough
right intercourse don't drive off of it
right drive off a cliff at the energy to
be killed
sorry right but but so I mean I think to
get true eroticism there have to be
limits okay alright and when anything
goes there's nothing erotic is left and
that's what we're left with now